je bouge pas
aucun fonctionnaire ne sera au courant
de ton infiltration là-bas
[Musique]
faut qu'on garde une veille sur cette
zone le ministre sous le dossier en
direct c'est quoi ton nom déjà Greg
ça rend complètement parano
j'ai envie de rester avec toi je crois
[Musique]
merde
[Applaudissements]
ça a aucun sens s'acharner sur ce qui se
battent pour l'intérêt général c'est pas
toi qui voulais défendre la démocratie
il y a toujours des conséquences si sa
mère
15 jours c'est notre objectif ce qui
compte c'est la volonté de communication
du gouvernement je te jure qu'on va
aller jusqu'au bout
tout ce qu'on a construit ça sert à rien
face à la bulldozer là il cherche la
taupe si je pars maintenant je suis
foutu
[Musique]
est-ce que tu veux vraiment
si je devais me barrer tu viendras avec
moi c'est trop tard
[Musique]